let's talk about the e-cigarette there
have been these amazing reports coming
out lately that there are several people
who have experienced some kind of crazy
lung disease Robin the whole thing is
nuts this [ __ ] idiot that works for
me Sal I love the guy but he's killing
himself
he's vapes because he wanted to quit
smoking okay I get it
where is it that that's safe you're
taking chemicals and breathing them into
your lungs I thought this was supposed
to help him quit Wow what are you doing
yeah elevant what are you up to have you
quit the vaping I've cut down by about
50 percent I don't smoke it in the house
anymore
why would you why would you even risk
putting it in your life you're taking a
chemical I agree I agree it's stupid and
I really do want to can't stop I've cut
down and I thank you babe this is the
juice and this thing has a skull and
crossbones on the bottle I used to buy
it from India with a skull and cross I
stopped that one and now they're all
over the place these vape shops and what
do you see what's happening to people
yes yes I'm concerned and even Richard
told me he doesn't like walking with Sal
because he's surrounded by a cloud and
yeah I I feel bad about and I purposely
blow it away yeah and it's right in his
face
yeah Richard what do you want to say
honey you gotta stop I'm not with honey
with me honey - he goes hey I've been
trying to get sound to stop for years
and now I'm really freaking worried
about him
and I don't I hate this and I've walked
through this cloud when I walk with
indepence station every day and it
worries me about my health - but I feel
too bad to like force him to stop but I
just want him to do it for his own
health if I sup I read in the paper that
vaping was causing people to go in with
lung disease into the hospital it would
take me all of one second to quit you
can't conquer vaping I can I will
and don't say take that stupid thing
plugged in and throw it out Richard go
throw that dump - yeah he should dump
the dice out right now is that your
juice how much other cause 20 bucks
give it to me I'll throw down better if
you double excuse
turn over your pen and you juice you
want me to throw it out are you done
with it I'm done with it I'm done let me
see this you put this in your lungs you
[ __ ] what's wrong with you warning
I don't know how nobody could know what
it is you want me to throw this out are
you done with it I'm I'm gonna be you
know what I throw it out or not you tell
me I don't want to do I here's your pen
here's your juice you want me to throw
it out right now it's a big moment do it
you're strong enough
I'll throw garbage right now and you're
done do it alright here I go
one this is your vape pen how much did
this cost forty dollars and you're done
with it I'm done with it
it's not worth my life and now garbage
what's this what's a babe juice you're
done done that's a man now you're a
[ __ ] man not a [ __ ] good job honey
how hard was that not hard at all it's
hard hard well then you're done with it
so now you're free of that addiction
alright alright alright get out now and
yeah that you've been straightened out
and you can go back to your room sit
there now and going through through
withdrawal by yourself alright goodbye